الى الضفه الغربيه حيث اعلن الهلال الاحمر
الفلسطيني اصابه اربعه فلسطينيين برصاص
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وصفت اصابه
احدهم بالخطير خلال مواجهه اندلعت في
بلدتي بلعا وعبت شرقيه طولكرم في الضفه
الغربيه وافادت مصادر محليه بان قوات
الاحتلال اقتحمت الاحياء وانتشرت فيها
لاعتقال من تسميهم مطلوبين وتمركزت في وسط
بلده بلعا حيث اندلعت مواجهات مع
فلسطينيين اثناء تصديهم لعمليه الاقتحام
وقامت قوات الاحتلال بتدمير واحراق محل
تجاري واطلاق قنابل الصوت عليه قبل ان
تنسحب كما اقتحمت قوات الاحتلال ايضا بلده
بنعيم شرق الخليل وشرعت في دهم وتفتيش
منازل المدنيين كما اقتحمت مدينه دورا
جنوب الخليل ومنطقه تله الصمود في مسافر
يطا جنوب المدينه واطلقت قوات الاحتلال
الرصاصه باتجاه سياره اسعاف تابعه للجنه
الشعبيه لخدمات مخيم العروب شمال
الخليل كما اقتحمت قوات الاحتلال بلدتي
قطنا والقبه شمال غرب القدس ومدينه
قلقيليه شماليه الضفه الغربيه للمره
الثانيه فجر اليوم ودهمت احياء عده في
المدينه وقد اعتقلت قوات الاحتلال عددا من
الشبان كما اندلعت مواجهه مسلحه مع
مقاومين فلسطينيين ولا تزال قوات الاحتلال
تحاصر احياء عده بذري البحث عن مطلوبين
لديها دهمت قوه الاحتلال الاسرائيليه
البلده القديمه ومحيطها في مدينه نابلس
وافادت مراسله الجزيره ان اشتباكات عنيفه
اندلعت بين قوات الاحتلال ومقاومين
فلسطينيين حاولوا التصدي لعمليه الاقتحام
وكانت قوات الاحتلال قد انسحبت من المدينه
بعد تدمير مطبعه لاستاذ جامعي معتقل منذ
شهر في سجون الاحتلال وبعد انسحابها باقل
من نصف ساعه عادت واقتحمت المدينه وتوجهت
صوب البلده
القديمه